-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
While touring the demilitarized
zone on Thursday,
Vice President Kamala Harris
mistakenly said
the U.S. has, quote,
"an alliance
with the Republic
of North Korea."
It's a huge blunder that many
are calling presidential.
[ Laughter ]
Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas's wife Ginni
testified on Thursday before the
house committee investigating
the Capitol attack in
a four-hour closed-door session,
and no matter how much
the committee begged her,
she would not open the door.
[ Laughter ]
The National Archives said last
week they still did not have
custody of all missing records
from former President Trump's
administration.
And this is absolutely
the first time Donald Trump
has ever fought someone
for custody.
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] It's all yours.
[Normally] According
to newly-released documents,
the FBI spent years
surveilling the late singer
Aretha Franklin, which isn't
surprising if you've seen
and of her performances
from the '60s.
[ Laughter ]
So I guess that's an FBI agent.
Ordering from a giant menu.
[ Laughter ]
The FBI used to dress like
"Inspector Gadget."
[ Laughter ]
When he was preparing to leave
Walter Reed Medical Center
in 2020 after being treated
for the coronavirus,
then-President Trump reportedly
told aides he wanted to exit
the hospital in a wheelchair
and then stand up to reveal
a Superman shirt, you know, just
like Superman would never do.
[ Laughter ]
A little league baseball card of
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg
sold an auction last week,
and even then, they knew he
wasn't going to be an athlete.
[ Laughter ]
The New York sandwich shop
Katz's Delicatessen in Alidoro
announced the release of a
New York subway-themed sandwich.
The way it works is you eat
the sandwich while a stranger
masturbates next to you.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
That's right.
Katz's will release
the so-called 1904 Signature Sub
this month
in honor of the subway system's
118th birthday.
And if you're wondering what
the subway was like
118 years ago,
ride it.
[ Laughter ]
Disney World fully reopened
to its normal hours
over the weekend
after Hurricane Ian,
and it's pretty much the same,
except now, the whole place
smells like wet Goofy.
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
Oh, you're all on board for
the subway masturbator.
We draw the line at wet Goofy.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Chipotle is set
next month to begin testing
its new kitchen robot
named Chippy.
And to give you the authentic
Chipotle experience,
the robot will be high as hell.
[ Laughter ]
[Robot voice]
"What did you say again?"
[ Laughter ]
Ha ha ha ha.
[Normally] That was a monologue,
everybody.